buenas tardes es todo un placer estar
aquí en toledo
namasté para todos
lo cierto es que hay un mundo que está
implosionando hay un mundo que se está
derrumbando de una manera veloz que está
enfermo y ese mundo es el mundo
analógico el mundo
y hay muchas pruebas de ello entraremos
después y luego hay un mundo el mundo
digital el mundo no analógico que está
tomando unos niveles de capilaridad
inmensos en todo el mundo hay un montón
de hechos que atestiguan esto de datos
estadísticos en este momento en el que
todo el mundo para explorar the big data
y the machine learning y de algoritmos
que estamos entrando en una
matematización de la sociedad bien
estamos entrando en una matematización
de la sociedad no olvidemos la parte
cualitativa no caigamos en un data ismo
la patología del dato no caigamos en
ello hay muchas formas muchas fuentes de
sabiduría muchas formas de aproximarnos
a la realidad al objeto que estamos
analizando
lo cierto es que hay
+ d
7 billones de teléfonos inteligentes
corregiría hay alrededor de 3 billones
de teléfonos inteligentes de smartphones
y el resto de camps sounds o teléfonos
no inteligentes los primeros teléfonos
móviles con los que empezamos a
funcionar hay una distinción clara por
tanto esto ya genera una gran distinción
con el mundo exclusivamente analógico
donde teníamos teléfonos que estaban
conectados a la red vía cable esto
produce un cambio tremendo y es parte de
lo que es este mundo nuevo digital que
está tomando una dimensión tremenda tan
tremenda que muchos lugares del mundo
están siendo urbanizados gracias a los
teléfonos inteligentes a internet como
base y a todo el ecosistema que ha
producido internet que sin duda será
considerado yo no lo veré pero como la
revolución más importante de toda la
humanidad pero no sólo por el hecho en
sí
e internet que crea una gran fisura
entre un mundo y otro sino por todo el
ecosistema que está dando lugar internet
y lo que está por venir loft la famosa
inteligencia artificial seguimos
analizando tenemos alrededor de 200 mil
millones de objetos ya conectados o casi
casi faltan algunos pocos por conectarse
en el año 2020 estamos hablando de una
nueva concepción donde el cliente el
usuario el ciudadano debería ser debido
a estos avances tecnológicos el centro
de todos los estadios de la cadena de
valor de las empresas el centro de las
ciudades el centro de los comercios
debería ser el centro y que reclama ser
apropiadamente servido y no infra
servido hay muchos pensadores que están
hablando de que ya estamos
enfrentándonos a la cuarta revolución
industrial sobre todo cuando ya pasamos
a la parte de la inteligencia artificial
algoritmos que van a ser capaces de
evitar la colisión de los coches
pero la realidad y por eso creo que es
importante el lema de la revolución
personal al final da igual estos cambios
que pensadores tecnólogos filósofos
empresarios emprendedores están
impulsando lo importante para que se
produzca un verdadero cambio es la
revolución interior porque a pesar de
todo lo que estamos constatando de todos
estos avances tecnológicos y científicos
que no olvidemos que son irreversibles a
diferencia de los cambios sociales en
los que puede haber involución
la brecha que crea un descubrimiento
científico tecnológico queda ahí para
siempre se puede ocultar se puede
demorar pero ya está ahí ya se ha
descubierto una vacuna para una
enfermedad ya se ha descubierto un
dispositivo que hace una serie de cosas
o un robot que hace otras eso es
irreversible pero lo que no lo que lo
que dificulta realmente esto es ver lo
que sucede hoy en día en las ciudades
tenemos imágenes como éstas que están
detrás de mí que indican masificación
masificación en la ciudad masificación
en los comercios masificación en los
aeropuertos colapso colapso colapso
sobre todo en las ciudades el siglo 21
va a ser el siglo de las ciudades y de
los continentes de los grandes espacios
con tamaños similares a los de china por
eso mucha gente que habla hasta incluso
de espacios tan ibéricos precisamente
porque estos continentes el continente
asiático cuando mira hacia otras partes
no mira cosas pequeñas no quiere tratar
con cosas pequeñas no quiere impulsar o
invertir en cosas pequeñas quiere
impulsar grandes espacios por tanto no
tiene mucho sentido en este momento
estar impulsando la creación de nuevos
estados nación y esto es un ejemplo de
lo que está ocurriendo en las ciudades
donde se produce la mayor concentración
de estos gadgets de teléfonos
inteligentes porque está la mayor parte
de la población más del 50 por ciento de
la población mundial ya estamos cerca de
que el 80 por ciento de la población
mundial esté viviendo en ciudades y eso
qué quiere decir que o hacemos una
optimización de los recursos o realmente
esas ciudades esos continentes no van a
ser sostenibles es decir no vamos a
durar y ya ha habido otras
civilizaciones en el pasado que han
perecido previamente antes de un cambio
climático como por ejemplo la
civilización maya
y también eran avanzados para esa época
tecnológicamente de otra manera nosotros
pero eran muy avanzados cuidado con esto
cuidado con no utilizar las herramientas
que tenemos si hay otras que alguien os
diga las herramientas tecnológicas que
tenemos para hacer un mejor uso y
aprovechamiento de los recursos una
mejor asignación de los recursos
mucha gente recursos limitados hay que
utilizar herramientas para cambiar esta
situación una vez más del colapso de
masificación que son llamadas también de
atención para potenciales actos
terroristas
tenemos que manejar mucho mejor los
flujos tanto de información como de
personas y esto lo puede hacer la
tecnología lo cierto es que a día de hoy
no lo estamos utilizando posiblemente es
un problema de mentalidad posiblemente
lo que existe una vez más es una
desconexión entre una minoría de la
población que con mayor o menor
efectividad está empujando unos cambios
y los legisladores los reguladores
otro tipo de actores que no están
empujando esta revolución digital
tecnológica que nos va a permitir una
mayor eficiencia que nos va a permitir
sobre todo liberar tiempo
dinero y recursos en estos momentos
8 millones 8 millones de norteamericanos
están desperdiciando muchísimo tiempo
dentro de las ciudades y porque lo están
haciendo lo están haciendo porque no hay
una compensación no hay una coordinación
los avances tecnológicos están ahí sin
embargo las infraestructuras no se están
cambiando al mismo ritmo podemos hablar
de sistemas y ot de sistemas
inteligentes
podemos decir sistemas de datos no
distribuidos distribuidos un sqlserver
montgó y ya tenemos un sistema 7 pero
realmente estamos preparados para que
haya una comunicación en tiempo real una
transferencia de conocimiento en tiempo
real que es una de las grandes fuerzas
de internet como lo fue en su día la
imprenta que permitió la transferencia
de conocimiento que permitió que
shakespeare escribirse sus obras porque
había podido leer a cervantes están las
ciudades preparadas tenemos la
conectividad de quien depende esta
conectividad tenemos los dispositivos
tenemos internet no tenemos la
conectividad 5g para que esto ocurra no
tenemos las infraestructuras
las adecuadas para que pueda haber una
conexión de estos dispositivos que los
edificios hablen con los teléfonos que
las personas hablen con los edificios
esto es posible porque está siendo tan
complicado una vez más por la
desconexión empresa empresarios
reguladores y actores políticos que son
los que tienen que empujar este cambio
lo que los usuarios y clientes no pueden
tolerar más es que en ciudades como roma
como bogotá
se pierdan alrededor de 208 días
de nuestras vidas mayormente porque
estamos metidos en atascos porque
estamos colapsando porque hay retrasos
porque hay demoras esto es lo que
tenemos que darnos cuenta cuando estamos
acelerando por un lado las
comunicaciones a través de las
mensajerías a través de los servicios de
mensajerías estamos acelerando las
transacciones electrónicas los pagos
como es posible que después colapse mos
dentro de la ciudad como es posible que
actualmente teniendo la posibilidad de
soluciones diferentes de movilidad
se esté generando mucho más tráfico
una vez más un problema regulatorio está
bien que tengamos aplicaciones
utilizando el gps localizan se localizan
al cliente a que es el taxista o el
conductor con el cliente ve todo esto
hace de la ciudad más sostenible porque
porque en vez de estar vagando ese
vehículo por las calles a la persona que
demanda el vehículo en un sitio se le
manda el más cercano y todo esto está
controlado por algoritmos eso es mucho
mejor aunque menos romántico que
levantar la mano de repente y esperar a
que un taxi te recoja y es mucho más
efectivo y menos costoso que llamar a un
call center
porque ahí tenemos una serie de
intermediarios que hacen que este
proceso no sea transparente cuando lo
utilizamos a través de una emisora no es
transparente no vemos lo que pasa el
cliente no está en el centro de la
cadena de valor por tanto no está
empoderado qué es lo que hace la
tecnología y se siente muchas veces
infra servido porque teniendo estas
soluciones en muchas ciudades aunque en
otras se les expulse porque tienen
nuestras opciones
sigue habiendo tanta polución tanta
tanta contaminación 8 millones de
personas 9 mueren al año exclusivamente
por la polución muchas de ellas también
mueren por el ruido o tienen fatiga
nerviosa o estrés debido al ruido al
ruido que es superior a 50 decibelios
que es lo que está ocurriendo lo que
está ocurriendo es que una de las
uno de los fundamentos para estas
soluciones móviles digitales puedan
hacer su trabajo es la reducción del uso
del vehículo privado pero si todavía
encontramos familias o unidades
familiares o centros de trabajo en donde
todo individuo tiene un coche y maneja
un coche y va y se mueve en la ciudad
con un coche de cuatro personas aunque
sólo esté el la combinación de esta de
esta modalidad que no se está reduciendo
considerablemente más nuevas soluciones
de movilidad que para poder sobrevivir
para poder crecer para poder sostenerse
como empresa tienen que utilizar por
ejemplo soluciones o estrategias de
gamification o de marketing utilizando
descuentos está haciendo que muchas
personas al final acaben no utilizando
el coche particular a lo mejor pero
utilizando estas soluciones de movilidad
con descuentos para ir a por el pan para
moverse 200 metros estos al final cuál
es el problema es un problema al final
de mentalidad de revolución interior de
saber y cuestionarnos
qué tipo de consumo hacemos porque ese
consumo es el que está definiendo la
sociedad sea analógica o digital pero
ciertamente aunque el consumo no sea el
adecuado utilizando soluciones digitales
al menos podemos reducir el impacto cosa
que si unimos un consumo desaforado sin
soluciones digitales que optimicen las
transacciones el tránsito al final lo
que llegamos es a el colapso y a
desperdiciar nuestra vida gran parte de
nuestra vida inter ciudad dentro de la
ciudad o buscando aparcamiento que ya es
ridículo tirarse 20 30 40 minutos en las
grandes ciudades simplemente para buscar
aparcamiento cuando ya has llegado a tu
destino con lo que genera eso
no será más inteligente utilizar en el
futuro preparar la ciudad hay que
prepararlo también desde el punto de
vista arquitectónico y urbanístico para
que haya para que sólo los coches
autónomos se muevan por la ciudad y
cuando dejen una persona esté todo
conectado matemáticamente para que otra
persona suba y use el coche etcétera no
será mucho mejor esto que no haga falta
que estos coches tengan que realmente
aparcar se no será mucho mejor esto
bueno
muchos insisten en quedarse donde
estamos en este momento que donde
estamos es esto estas fotos no son
cuadros son fotos reales en la mayor
parte de los lugares y las ciudades del
mundo
por tanto y para terminar sería muy
interesante que hiciésemos todos un
esfuerzo para transformar nuestras
mentes en
graus mind en mentes que están
constantemente compitiendo con sí mismas
que se están auto superando que están
afrontando una revolución que permita
que permita o que sea buena o sea en
aras del interés general trascender los
intereses particulares en intereses
generales si tenemos esta revolución en
interior y realmente utilizamos estas
herramientas tecnológicas que hemos
descubierto entre todos estoy convencido
de que liberaremos tiempo lograremos
recursos y conseguiremos tener ciudades
sostenibles en nosotros está que
empujemos también a las administraciones
a los reguladores para que se informen
para que se documenten y sean capaces de
generar algo que tuvimos en el siglo 18
el más importante el contrato social de
uso y desde ese momento partes del que
no hemos logrado entendernos un contrato
social que incluya la tecnología
que trate temas como la igualdad que
trate temas como la seguridad y la
libertad pero introduciendo estos nuevos
avances tecnológicos y científicos
poniéndolos y eso es importante para eso
está la regulación poniéndolo realmente
al servicio de los ciudadanos ayudar a
liberar a los ciudadanos
y empoderar a estos ciudadanos esto es
algo que tenemos que hacer junto con un
con una comparación un benchmarking
de lo que sucede ahora con lo que ha
sucedido en el pasado aquí tenemos a un
gran arquitecto que dentro de poco va a
hablar y es una cosa que muchas veces no
se dice se habla de los coches
inteligentes de las aplicaciones pero no
se habla de los edificios es que los
edificios no son importantes dentro de
las ciudades pues es increíble que si
nos fijamos en muchas ciudades la mayor
parte de los materiales que seguimos
utilizando son materiales que ya se
utilizaban en el imperio romano
bueno alguno habrá que seguir utilizando
puede ser podemos ser utilizando pero
todos no pues no hay un problema a lo
mejor con el tema de la eficiencia
energética por utilizar cierto tipo de
materiales externo hay otros materiales
que puedan reforzar esta idea de ciudad
conectada de ciudad eficiente de ciudad
efectiva
estoy convencido de que sí pero una vez
más hay reguladores hay legisladores
están que no están aquí que no están
aquí y el resultado es el colapso la
masificación las colas tráfico ruido
polución en pleno siglo 21 tenemos que
intentar evitar este tipo de imágenes
que lo único que hablan es de que desde
luego estamos muy lejos de tener
momentos de felicidad muchas gracias
[Aplausos]